good evening everybody thank you for
attending this evening this is the
licensing appeals committee meeting on
the 30th of september 2021.
an emergency evacuation announcement
first of all should we be required to
evacuate the building would you please
leave the building via the hall entrance
doors turn right walk straight past the
canteen and through the external doors
on the right and out of the car park
which is the assembly point
please do not delay your evacuation to
collect any belongings please do not
return to the building until given
permission to do so by council staff
please note that the meeting will be
audio recorded
and please switch off mobiles or turn
them to silent
members there is a need to use
microphones during the meeting
when i invite you to speak please wait
until there is a microphone in front of
you before speaking as microphones are
needed for the hearing loop and for the
audio recording
please wear possible assistant passing
microphones to each other and use the
hand gel and antibacterial wipes on the
tables if you touch the microphones
members voting will be done on a show of
hands in line with the constitution
i will ask for a show of hands
for and then against recommendations and
we'll also ask for a show of hands for
those wishing to abstain from voting
agenda item one
apologies have been received from
councillor tracy knight are there any
other apologies
no
thank you very much
agenda item two substitute members
we have no we have not been advised in
advance of any substitute members are
there any no thank you
agenda item three
um
no visiting members a week done that bit
agenda item four
minutes of the meeting held on the 17th
of november is everybody happy with
those minutes
great
thank you very much
agenda item five to receive declarations
of interest
are there any declarations of interest
members
council carter
uh yeah a lot to declare a pecuniary
interest as i'm a hackney taxi driver
thank you on item six
thank you are there any other
no thank you very much
agenda item six formal adoptation of the
rocha district council hackney carriage
and private hire licensing policy
the council's principal
licensing officer stephen greener will
present this report
thank you mr greener
i don't think it's working
um
the department of transport published
the statutory taxi and private hire
vehicle standards
which has set out the minimum standards
to regulate better the taxi
vehicle sector focusing on
and the government now expects these
standards to be implemented unless there
is compelling local reasons not to do so
the new policy will jump forward a bit
um
when formulating a taxi by the fire and
vehicle policy the primary and
overriding must be to protect the
coverage
the importance is
discussion making
failure to disclose information
as part of the process there is a
consultation process
and under 6.2
on the 21st of july
november of 2020
about the conclusion
is point in relation to the um 67.4
percent did not support the seven
emotionals
standards and most of the responses
after the twelve
in the public consultation in march 2021
the council launched a public
consultation on the proposed carriage
the council only received 11 responses
eighty-one uh
um
thank you very much dave thank you
does anybody have any questions
counseling sure
thank you steve for the report very
comprehensive but i must admit on 6.2
i'm very disappointed that there was
only 187 responses
um
surely every
one
of the drivers should it should have
been compulsory to answer this because
40 percent
40.1
40.1
supported the requirement of
safeguarding training
which i think is absolutely appalling
that we've got cab drivers out there not
supporting safeguarding if they don't
support it then they shouldn't be
driving because that i wouldn't want my
child my mother or anyone going in the
taxi that doesn't support
say that safeguarding driver has had
training um
is
thank you thank you very much are there
any other questions
sorry
council ahoy
i just i don't think your microphone's
on just in just a moment
but i think perhaps 10.1 should have
referred to that then because we're
saying at the moment
there are few no impacts
so clearly there are positive impacts
from what you're saying and i think
that's the idea of having the equality
in diversity implications in that we can
say there are positive or negative
impacts
so perhaps
yeah
it's okay i'm picking everybody up on
equality and diversity implications at
the moment i just think it should be
used more
i thank you
thank you very much councillor are there
any other
council
questions
thank you chairman um
steve um you you raised the point that
um 67.4
did not support the seven motoring
offenses
um i don't know if you want to give us
any more details on that because
it's actually quite um surprising if not
shocking because
um
it does say a minor traffic or vehicle
related offence
which is one that does not involve the
loss of life however it includes driving
under the influence of drink or drugs
driving waste
using a mobile phone and has not
resulted in injury to a person or damage
to any property so
they seem quite reasonable reasons
so
is there any background as to why they
um
the vast majority are on zero points on
their license um
i don't know why
they're opposed to it what it
12 says and therefore ask for it to
match the same
the institute of licensing policy has
had in place
um
um
um mayor chairman through you
um i don't know if there's anything
around possible
um information that can be passed to um
the taxi drivers i know safer roads
essex will be able to give you some
statistics of road accidents caused by
drink drugs um or mobile phone use or
any handheld device
um i i'm quite pleased that we do um
have it at seven points chairman
um we're looking after the people now
well not just our district but people
are using taxes in our district okay
as far as i'm aware it's a
self-reporting system is that correct
excellent thank you very much
do we have any other questions
counselor
ft
sorry
sorry lauren i've got this one
just for clarification on 6.29
where it's got
10
11
12
13
and on 11 it says conviction or
completion of sentence
and every other one says completion of
sentence should
that may be
the same as for clarification
completion of any sentence or driving
being imposed completion of any sentence
driving pen potion that one is
conviction or completion which is the
handheld
so could we maybe take prediction put
completion like all the others or
just for clarity
thank you
okay thank you with that slight
amendment um are there any other
questions
right then members um
there's one recommendation set out and
that is that the hackney carriage
carriage and private hire license
licensing policy 2021-26
be approved i recommend i'd like to
propose that that's the case do we have
a secondary
we have a second to thank you
councilwoman
right can i see a show of hands please
for the
proposal
okay against please
and any abstentions
okay
that's carrot thank you very much thank
you
we're on item seven now aren't we yes
yeah item seven thank you uh pavement
permissions
council's principal licensing officer
stephen greener will present this report
once again thank you steve thank
you very much
okay thank you
is
for another 12 months
so how does this impact on existing
policies it basically extends the policy
for a further 12 months until the 30th
september 2022
there's currently five frances across
the district taking advantage of the
legislation
the current application fee has been set
at meal cost
and the legislation allows the fees for
up to 100 pounds
to support the administration cost of
processing all applications and it is
proposed that from the first of october
2021
that the
fee
is set at 100 pounds
the process allows an appeal process and
the cost of the committee
world
and
is
thank you thank you very much mr green
are there any questions from members
council ahoy
yeah thank you for the report um
comprehensive in comprehensive as ever
um
i was
on this committee when we decided not to
charge
um
i think the
same rationale is still there for not
charging the high street is still very
delicate i'm
surprised there was 35 i think there
were five last year who were using it
and there's only five
i think
given the state of the
hospitality industry in this country
given the
restrictions they still have
within trade to a certain extent
a hundred pounds doesn't say seem a lot
i know to many people but i think it can
make a big difference to some of these
businesses um
i'm not saying never charge
i'm saying perhaps i would support
deferring this
for a year
and then viewing it again to see
how circumstances have changed for these
businesses i'm just really concerned
it's one it's giving the wrong
impression until it is costing the money
we're trying to help the high street
recover at the moment i think this will
give the wrong impression and it won't
help them
thank you
thank you councillor do you have any
answer to that at all so i think i'm
actually moving a motion to do that
actually which i didn't quite stay did i
say you're probably quite confused
because i was moving a motion to say two
further
so i the the three that
that we agreed to postpone the the
hundred pound administration fee to be
reviewed at the first of october 2022 on
the 30th of september 22's do you have a
second for that please
okay thank you
council mcpherson
thank you chairman um
just before um just a question then
stephen um
councillor mr hoy mentioned um there was
only about five applications do we um
see any increase um i'm just thinking of
workloads
um
[Music]
um
yeah we do but this mr green no mr
greenery is answering the question from
from councillor mcpherson just just a
moment please
thank you okay thank you um no other
questions at the moment uh councillor
can you clarify your your
amendment please just certainly i think
i need to and that we changed the item
with the third item on page 7.4
but at the moment it says that it be
agreed that with effect for first of
october 2021 the council will charge 100
payment
permit fee for all applications whether
new or renewed
i'd like to recognize the fact we are
we have talked about it and it's there
in the background but i'd like to change
it to
that will be a grade that
the committee agrees
a charge of 100 pound
for a payment
payment permit fee
for all applications
but to suspend its introduction
pending review
at the first meeting after 30th of
september 2022. thank you i'm hopeful
are you still in agreement with that
counsellor
thank you very much
councillor shaw
does it have is it relevant to the to
the amendment
i actually would support this motion as
well chairman okay thank you
right we'll go to a show of hands we
made for the amendment at this moment um
so it's item three on the
recommendations so the amendment is as
as councillor stated can i see a show of
hands for that amendment please
that's unanimous thank you that's
carried um for the following for the
three amendment for the three um
sorry uh councillor fd
thank you chairman uh mr greener on uh
7.3 8.5
where it's got without breaching social
distancing rules could we add while they
still apply
just to make that more relevant
without breaching social distancing
rules can we put in while they apply
thank you
right thank you with the amendments i
intend if in agreement if everybody is
in agreement that we take these on block
is everybody in agreement with that
please
thank you very much
so um
right the proposal is that we accept
these with the amendments these three
recommendations so
could i see a vote for all that
recommend that we'll accept this please
that's your nana thank you very much
that is carried thank you
item eight consultation process for
street trading policy review the
council's principal licensing officer
steve greener is busy tonight
thank you we'll present this report
sorry just a moment councillor fd
chairman just a declaration of
non-pecuniary interest to be in whitford
parish council
and white queen parish council
thank you councillor mcpherson the same
i presume
that's the same i presume
could you put me down for one of those
please thank you
mr greener thank you
there's been a number of changes in the
legislation over the years and it's been
appropriate for this
to ensure that this policy is fit for
purpose it also follows the most
up-to-date guidance and recommendations
a copy of the new street
and additional controls
authorities then after consultation
consider all the representations and
then produce report back to here with
the findings following the consultation
at that time to then the licensing
committee
following the report
and
um
such as mobile vehicles including ice
cream traders
and
8.12
um
do we have any questions
council ohio first thank you
a few questions a little bit con
confused
on
in the actual
your report you
there are designated roads which are
quite substantial and there's a few in
holbridge obviously
in one introduction scope in paragraph
1.2
it says the council has designated all
of its roads for paths fields and
administrative areas as consent streets
for street trading purposes does that
mean that we no longer have designated
roads but the whole area
and fields
so the recreation ground in holbridge
will be a
would be licensed um
it seems
quite a leap to go from the roads we had
to then covering every single area i'm a
bit concerned about it
i i've read the report and i understand
what it says but i'm
really trying to understand what
what the underlying purpose is what
we're really trying to achieve with this
it seems like we try and
it's i i can't
see that it's trying to achieve what the
report says we try to achieve it just
seems a very blanket
coverall to try and cover everywhere and
i'm concerned that's the first concern
i've got
three others really
so
how would it have i know it's got in
there about markets and i didn't quite
follow the rationale does that cover
rainy market would be exempt
so if you say hockey parish council we
need to do a market out in its forecourt
would that need a license
right okay and
it wherever it did it now as long as
it's 15 meters off the pub the highway
or
right this is where i think it starts to
get quite excessive um
are unadopted roads covered or are they
just covered within 15 metres of the
highway
okay that's easy you mentioned ice cream
guys because that's for the other ones i
wrote down so i mean apparently they've
got to send the send the application in
with the area they want covered in red
that doesn't seem very feasible for an
ice cream van
do they just circle the whole district
in red
okay
i am
uncomfortable with the sweeping nature
of it as you can tell
um
i'm not sure whether now or perhaps
something to be raised when the public
consultation comes back
to see what the public think of it as
well
um
because
otherwise it seems quite sensible in
many ways but i'm just concerned about
the scope and putting so many people in
for it
does it cover children said in lemonade
on their drive
technically
right
unless they're businesses
i don't know what difference is between
the drive cake driveway enough four goal
for instance this is where i'm a bit
good bit
this is where it gets technical
um
and the final bit you mentioned
duplication
surely if we're using this license to
crack down on
hygiene issues what's wrong with our
normal route for cracking down on
hygiene issues which would be through
the scoring process which i think they
would still have to apply for wouldn't
they
so it seems like we're duplicating some
work
sorry chairman i think i've raised my
concerns i've probably
probably won't photography at this point
but i just want my concerns no that's
not in the minutes obviously there will
be thank you absolutely fine thank you
very much council hi
councilman mr weston
thank you very much chairman a very
comprehensive report just a question i
want to ask obviously this is ruby
street trading is there a different
policy to deal with um trading in on
places like uh hockley
woods and fates that go on is there a
different policy or is that going to be
included in this policy
right thank you thank you jim
thank you councillor western uh
councillor missy shaw
thank you chairman um as steve very
comprehensive reporter as per usual um
as steve alluded to there has been
ice cream wars
this year um which are getting out of
hand where police have been called
etcetera
will this stop the south end ice cream
vans coming in because or what maybe
whoever
deals with them in south end licensing
team be told they've got to apply for
a license to come into our rochefort
district because i know with southend
they're only allocated certain streets
they're not allowed to go
beyond that in southend but that's why
they're coming over to us and this is
why we're getting the ice cream
wars
in front of children everything and this
is i think we've got to stop this so
this could be very good if we can get
this done
thank you very much councillor shaw are
there any other questions
thank you members if it's um in
agreement i would like to we have two
recommendations
uh recommendation one that the timeline
outline in paragraph 5.1 of the report
be agreed
and also that the draft street trading
policy be approved are you happy for us
to take those two recommendations on
block
agreed thank you very much
it's all right
right first of all then we'll do it
separately thank you council hawaii um
recommendation one and that's the
timeline outlined in paragraph five one
as a report be agreed and i see a show
of hands in favor please
i should animus thank you very much
and
item two that the draft street training
policy be approved may i see a show of
hands in favor please
thank you very much
thank you very much
and those against please
not against any abstentions
thank you very much councillors thank
you
those recommendations are approved thank
you councillors
as far as i can see that concludes the
business for this evening and i'd like
to thank you all for attending thank you
so much
you